[Música]
y en esta sección hoy nos vamos hasta el
Salvador allí el gobierno de nayib
bukele extendió por décimo cuarta vez el
estado de excepción tras la muerte de un
policía presuntamente a manos de
pandilleros esto pese a las denuncias de
ongs y organismos internacionales sobre
abusos de poder y presuntas violaciones
a los Derechos Humanos bukele volvió a
decir hoy a través de Twitter que
meterán en prisión a todos los asesinos
para que no salgan jamás para ampliar
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal en
San Salvador Vladimir Chamorro Vladimir
es la décimo cuarta prórroga de este
régimen de excepción en el país hasta
cuándo podrá ampliarse y cuáles son las
últimas acciones que se han llevado a
cabo
Hola sí las autoridades de seguridad han
sido empáticos que el régimen de
excepción se extenderá las veces que sea
necesario Hasta que el último miembro de
las pandillas sea encarcelado este día
pues se ha dado una vuelta de tuerca a
la drástica estrategia de seguridad con
la implementación de un nuevo ser con
militar El quinto de este tipo en el
marco del régimen de excepción que
cumplen 14 meses que implica esto es una
mayor operatividad
de la de las fuerzas de seguridad
mayores bueno mayor número de
allanamientos en viviendas controles
vehiculares etcétera este último cerco
militar fue instalado instaurado en el
municipio de Nueva Concepción en el
norte del país luego del asesinato de la
gente policial primera vez que ocurre un
asesinato de este tipo durante el
régimen de excepción decir que podríamos
seguir esperando que te siga prorrogando
este régimen de excepción las veces
durante muchos meses hasta que como ha
dicho el mismo presidente bukele el
último pandero esté tras las rejas bueno
Vladimir Y es que bukele dice no
importarle las denuncias de ong sobre
presuntas violaciones de los Derechos
Humanos si comienza a haber nuevos
asesinatos podríamos ver más
recrudecimiento de la violencia de las
fuerzas de seguridad
efectivamente el presidente continúa con
su retórica en contra de las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
humanos tanto nacionales como
internacionales que se han manifestado
abiertamente por
digamos las denuncias o han expresado
las denuncias sobre abusos de autoridad
detenciones arbitrarias etcétera
podríamos estar esperando más asesinatos
es muy probable recordemos que si bien
hay más de 68.000 personas capturadas
muchos de ellos han según autoridades de
seguridad Son miembros de pandillas
otros no de estos
sesenta y ocho mil cinco mil han sido
liberados entonces podríamos esperar que
haya una recomposición de miembros de
pandillas que han huido del país
entonces Podrían haber más asesinatos es
muy probable y mayor recrudecimiento de
las políticas de seguridad también